in Avengers endgame the surviving heroes
wrestled with the reality that half of
all beings in the universe had been
snapped out of existence but that's not
all they wrestled with spoilers ahead
folks the trauma of the initial snap
plus the revelation that Thanos had
reduced the Infinity stones to atoms
effects each of Earth's Mightiest in
different ways most fans agree that
endgame depicted the range of emotions
in an excellent way unfortunately there
has been some serious backlash over how
one particular character and his
struggle with grief was portrayed in the
film that's right a lot of people are
outraged over fat Thor in endgame
Avengers end game saw the Asgardian god
of thunder Thor fight with overwhelming
feelings of failure for not protecting
Hulk Loki and Heimdall at the start of
Avengers infinity war and for not
killing Thanos when he had the chance to
Thor's guilt sent him to a dark place
mentally and emotionally and he appeared
after the five-year jump in endgame
having found comfort in alcohol
fortnight and high-calorie snacks
something I've been roasting in the Sun
for number of weeks now it's almost
ready he has a big beer belly scraggly
hair and a thick beard that would make
Lumberjacks jealous most of all Thor
isn't as confident or self-assured as he
used to be though he's still quite
chipper following that big reveal
several jokes are made at Thor's expense
throughout endgame with characters
poking fun at his robust figure they
joke that he looks like the dude from
The Big Lebowski quipped that he didn't
fall asleep but actually died in the
middle of an important meeting and jab
that he has Cheez Whiz coursing through
his veins
while some giggled along with the gags
many others found fault with it all
arguing that fat Thor in Avengers
endgame is problematic as it encourages
audiences to laugh at someone who
exhibits symptoms of depression alcohol
dependence and post-traumatic stress
disorder Lacey Jade Christie wrote at
the Guardian I had seriously conflicted
emotions about the physical appearance
of Thor Thor has seen war death and
destruction and as a result he has PTSD
I applaud Marvel for highlighting mental
illness particularly as it relates to
veterans but it could have been treated
more sensitively I had hoped that we
were past the point in history where we
are allowed to poke fun at fat people
Cosmopolitan's Emily Tannenbaum penned
her own piece about the new Thor writing
in part the point they're trying to make
is clear Thor is plagued by pts
DeeAnn mental health issues but instead
of tackling his issues head-on his
fellow team members repeatedly ridiculed
and belittled him for his appearance
specifically his weight many more took
issue with Fat Thor for a variety of
different reasons but some offered
rebuttals to the outrage / films even
Anderton was one such individual he
published an opinion piece arguing that
Avengers endgame actually handles the
heroes personal journey quite well as
someone who's struggled with weight loss
got bullied here and there in my younger
years and still carries a hefty belly of
my own this movie doesn't feel like body
shaming to me if anything it's about
time we had a chunky superhero and I can
only hope that Thor keeps this wait if
he's coming back around in guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 in the coming years in
the wake of the backlash and the
response to that criticism Avengers end
game screenwriters Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely spoke to vulture
about their vision for Thor's physical
and emotional transformation in the film
Markus explained that he and McFeely
didn't want to put Thor on a mission of
vengeance as that was basically his
entire arc in Avengers infinity war
[Music]
instead they wondered what he would look
act and feel like after facing failure
and losing family and friends the
screenwriter made it clear that there
was no ill intent in having Thor gained
weight Marcus explained we wondered okay
well what if he does become a sort of
depressive alcoholic and the weight gain
was just part and parcel of that State
of Mind we didn't go like let's chunk
him up it'll be hilarious I think he is
the ideal Thor at the end of the movie
and he's carrying some weight
hopefully Marvel Studios can take the
feedback to the new Thor and use that to
inform the characters post endgame
trajectory besides it's not like Thor is
the first character to be the brunt of a
few mean-spirited jokes about his weight
who you kidding
well you're one sandwich away from that
Yeah right Thor seems poised to appear
in the third Guardians movie so maybe he
and quill can both rock the dad bod
while zipping through space check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Avengers
endgame are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]